this week's session of the synthesis
workshop at simon's
so today's session is going to be on
algorithmic aspects of synthesis
and some interesting applications
our first speaker is professor loris
dantoni
who is an assistant professor in the
computer science department at the
university of wisconsin at madison
loris has worked on many aspects of
formal methods and programming languages
including program synthesis verifiable
machine learning
and topics in automata theory and
also personalized education and
today loris is going to focus on the
synthesis side of his research on
synthesis with guarantees
loris hi hi thanks for the introduction
and uh thank you for having me here uh
yes today i'm gonna talk about uh
essentially
most of my students uh chin helping
who's dissertation which has been about
how to add some interesting guarantees
to program synthesis so let's dive right
in and let me tell you what i mean by
guarantees in program synthesis so i'm
going to focus the conversation
on syntax guided synthesis but a lot of
the techniques that we present are
general
uh i just i'm going to use cytosis in
something that many of you know
where essentially we have a
specification
where we're looking for some program
with a certain property and here i'm
really meaning p
of x y is just so this way speeds on the
side but i'm looking
for a program p of x y that takes for
every input x and y returns something
greater than x something greater than y
and this either x or y and
i have a grammar of terms i'm looking
for
so in this case i have essentially a
linear integer
arithmetic expressions with if the
analysis
and i would like my synthesizer to give
me a program that satisfies the
specification and it's in the search
space so in this case the obvious one is
if x rather than y return x otherwise
return y
of course this is not the only problem
that satisfies the specification here
there is this other one for example that
has
two if the analysis and in this case the
two are equivalent and they both satisfy
the specification
and one is arguably better
and why not talking about this well
people have used scythes and
synthesis in general for a lot of things
uh here is just a slider it shows uh
some applications of science
and uh uh a few years ago with the chin
happening we say oh maybe we can use
cyborgs ourselves for one
application and we were working on
inverting on building a synthesizer that
could invert string transformers so
these are things like i give you a
base64 encoder can you automatically
synthesize the base64
decoder for me so a string a problem
that takes a string and outputs another
string i want to compute its inverse
and we were able to solve this problem
by basically building a lot of smaller
problems
at the character level that we were
given to cycle solvers
so you don't need to understand what i'm
doing here but i'm inverting essentially
some program and we we formulated and
give it to us a cyber solver in
particular the e-solver and we got this
pretty good program
and again you don't need to understand
but then when we gave the same
uh cytos problem to a different solver
we got a very different program
okay so we got a huge program that had a
bunch of fifth analysis and it was very
complicated
so i argue that program synthesis is
essentially a bit unpredictable
in this case essentially i have a search
space and what happened is that
in the set of solution spaces so in in
my in my subspace there were multiple
programs that satisfy the specification
so i called the solution space the set
of programs that satisfy the
specification
and what happened here is that we were
lacking a way to specify which solutions
were better than other
and then synthesize the best solution
according to this metric
so in this case we wanted the program at
the top but instead sometimes we got the
one on the right
so here is like my forest gump quote
it's like synthesis is like a box of
chocolate you never know what you're
gonna get
and so that's one of the problems that
we have in synthesis
another problem we have is that in terms
of unpredictability is that sometimes
maybe since these problems don't have
solutions so for example
if you have a search space that doesn't
contain any program that is in the
solution space
so the two areas joined most solvers out
there what they will do is they will
basically run forever timeout or not
terminate
and ideally you would like to be able to
produce a proof
that indeed there is no program in the
search space so you want to be able to
automatic
the same way we are very good at finding
problems we want to be able to prove
that there are no problems
so and this kind of started uh this
direction of chin happiness dissertation
about
how can we add some guarantees to
program synthesis
and um we worked on on a number of
things
so the first thing we worked on is this
ability to prefer solution when there
are multiple ones
so synthesis normally takes a
specification a search space
and can we also have a preference of
what solution
we want to synthesize can we
automatically prove when
there is no solution and and some work
i'm not going to talk about today but
maybe can we
generate a program that satisfies
instead of fully satisfying
a specification maybe satisfies a
probabilistic version of it like the
program is correct on 99
of the spec or is correct with a certain
probability
so let me talk about the first project
which is essentially this one of adding
some quantitative objectives
so the problem here again i have
essentially
my specification and i have my
search base and a cyber solver will
synthesize one program in this search
space that satisfy the specification
and in this case we have two programs
and we want a way to prefer the first
solution
like we don't like the second one the
second one seems silly here
we like the first one so how do we do
that
well the natural way to do that is to
basically
add some kind of quantitative costs to
the pro to the program synthesis problem
so in this case
what we did is let's just instead of
having a normal context for grammar
that describes sets of terms why don't
we make this grammar weighted
so that we can assign naturally cost to
terms
and uh so we call these q sizes for
quantitative cycles and essentially
the main change is that now instead of
just having a grammar your grammar comes
with some time
some costs so what does it mean
to give a weight a gospel program well
if you look at the program here
essentially what happens is just you can
take the parse tree
of this program and whenever you use a
production that has a non-zero cost
in this case i assume that everything
that isn't marked at zero cost
so in this case i have two productions
that cost one all the other one cost
zero
so basically this program is cost two
the point here is that the programmer
when specifying their synthesis problem
can provide this weighted grammar to me
okay so
as part of the specification
of the synthesis technology can provide
cost so
on top of having a qualitative
specification which is
what we want the program to do we can
have a quantitative specification that
says i want a program with a certain
cost
so programs now have weight costs so in
this case we have that
the the top program is cost one which is
smaller than the bottom program that
does cost
two so let's see what what what is then
a syntax guided synthesis problem with
quantitative objectives the cue service
problem
so we have the formula as before we have
something that we want to be true for
the program we are trying to synthesize
now we have a weighted grammar so
grammar with costs
and we have in an objective we want to
achieve in this case let's say we want
to minimize the cost
and so we don't only want to find a
program
that satisfies the specification and is
in the language
we also want that program to be the best
meaning that we want that there is no
better program there is no other program
in the search space that also satisfies
the specification
and it has smaller costs so this is a
natural optimization objective okay
based on the weights i assign in my
grammar i want to find the best program
the one with the smallest weight that
also satisfies the specification
but how do we do that so adding this
cost it clearly
it wasn't that much of a contribution we
have to figure out a way now to
build solvers that in this new domain
of uh basically is sideways problems
with quantitative objectives
we need to build solvers that can solve
these problems
so i'm going to show you essentially we
have devised the meta algorithm an
algorithm that can be used by any
existing cyber solver
and i'm going to show you with an
example what algorithm does
and and
hopefully that will make sense so this
is a q-size problem so i have a
quantitative objective so
i have a specification i have a weighted
grammar
and i want to find a program of minimal
cost okay
that satisfies the specification so what
can i do
well i can start with something that i
already know how to solve
so i already have to find i already know
how to find a problem a program that
doesn't have the best cost
so i can take a cycle solver
ignore the weights and just give the
same problem
so i'm going to give you a specification
i'm gonna give you a grammar
and i'm gonna say give me any program
you want in this grammar so there is no
cost here okay i just have the grammar
and let's say the synthesizer returns
this particular program
well now i can ask can you do better
than that
so i'm gonna basically restrict my
grammar
to only accept programs of better costs
so in this case and this is what we have
in our paper we have
an algorithm for doing this but i think
this example kind of gives away
a lot of the idea behind algorithm i'm
going to build a grammar
that basically uses neuron terminals to
represent
different costs so in this case i'm
trying to get a grammar
g less than two that represents all the
programs in
all the all the programs in g that have
cost
less than two so how can a program that
starts with start
have cost less than two well it either
has cost 0 or it has cost 1.
and how can a program have cost 0 well
it either is a composition of 2 programs
of
0 or so on and so forth so now the
interesting thing is that this program
is again a sideways program so this
program
does not use any weights
the weights are part of the
non-terminals there is no cost it's just
a normal grammar i just
introduced new non-terminals and now i
can call again a cycle
and the site the solver maybe this time
we return this program which happened to
have cost one
and now i can keep going so if i started
with whatever cost i can keep going and
keep going and keep going
so the cool thing about this is that i
built the solver for the q sliders
problem so the problem with quantitative
objectives
use inside the solver so this technique
can be reused by any
other cycle solver it's effective is a
form of linear search
and the theorem is that if you give me a
weighted grammar without negative
weights so only with positive ways i can
always build for you such a grammar
that g less than c that accepts all
programs of cost less than c
and actually in the paper we generalize
this result
also to multiplicative weights so if you
have probabilities you can also
use the same technique and
also for bounded negative weights so if
if your negative weights cannot go below
a certain threshold we also have a way
to
handle some negative weights so
essentially it's fairly general and
the whole theory is given in terms of
certain monoids and whatnot so
it's uh you you can support a firm a
number of interesting ways that appear
in practice in fact let me show you
about this approach so i showed you how
to do minimization
doing linear search how to minimize the
cost but you can actually also
put constraints that you want cost to be
let's say greater than three
why because uh i talk about context for
grammars but in cycles
effectively in all the benchmarks we
consider and i would say most benchmarks
you will only need regular three
grammars and so if you can do
g less than four you can then complement
the grammar and for free get all the
programs of cost
greater than three and similarly you can
compose cost using intersection because
regular trigram marks are closed under
all operations you want to have
and in fact you can even compose
multiple costs you can have multiple
metrics you can have a cost one that
would say is i want to minimize the
number of
analysis and maybe i want to minimize
the
some probability so essentially you can
compose multiple costs together
and so we implemented this so the deal
of our implementation is very simple
we just have a q cyclist implementation
and then we we create these intermediate
problems and use different solvers
to solve them using cycles and we were
able to
basically take a number of cycles
benchmarks add various objectives like
minimize the number of analysis minimize
the solution
minimize some probability probabilities
are very useful
in in synthesis because you can use them
to assign
you people have used them to train
models
of how likely a certain program is and
then you can use this to guide the
search
so you want to find the program with the
highest probability and you can also
just say compose weights where for
example
you want to first minimize the number of
if analysis and
after that you want to find the program
the smallest program of all the ones
with the fewest disk analysis
and you can see on the right the the
problems we generated
and the summary here is that essentially
you can
this works uh we were able for many of
these benchmarks to start with a program
that
the first program the decider solve a
return wasn't the best one
but then by doing these iterative
updates we were able to find a better
program
and the interesting thing though is that
only for 14
of the 16 benchmarks we could optimize
we could prove optimality
meaning for two of these benchmarks we
weren't able to show that you couldn't
do better
okay so just to summarize
we basically we we have this solvent
that iteratively builds zygus problems
and he says can you do better can you do
better
and at some point we weren't able to
show that you could not do better
like basically we weren't able to solve
the next problem
let's look at this and this brings us to
the
other question i mentioned at the
beginning which is
remember i got here to the point where i
say is there a program of less less
of cost less than two and we found this
problem here we found the if the
analysis
qci goes now will ask is there a problem
of cost less than one
and the grammar for less than one is the
one you see here is basically
is only linear terms without if analysis
and the function we are trying to
compute here is the max function
and there is no way to implement the max
function using a program
in this grammar so there is no way to
say x plus y plus
n or a x plus b
y plus n that can implement the max
function
and so basically this brought us to the
problem that these cytos
we were encountering inside those
problems that didn't admit a solution
and this was the the essentially the
other problem i mentioned at the
beginning of the talk which is we want
to be able sometimes to prove
that no bad no program exists we cannot
find a program that has this part there
is a solution we cannot find a program
for this particular problem
so this is the next project that have
been worked on which was basically how
can we prove analyzability in syntax
guided synthesis
and so here the problem is i have an
analyzable problem so i need to output
the proof
that there doesn't exist a program in
the search space that does what i want
and because the grammar is infinite this
this is an undecidable problem
and sanjit for example has interesting
results on this on this domain
so before starting and showing our
technique i'm going to make a simple
one assumption is that i can use instead
of trying to prove that the whole pro
problem is on the side is uh
unrealizable i can focus on examples
because uh it's a little easier why
can't i focus on examples in many cases
something like sieges an algorithm that
basically gives you examples
as part of the specification will be
enough to show realizability
so for the program we have here the max
if you use these four examples
it's already enough to show that already
not only there doesn't exist a solution
to the problem
across infinite examples
for the particular problem problem
already you cannot find the max of these
four pairs of numbers
using the grammar we had before so i'm
going to just focus on examples
and that's okay because if i prove
analyzability over a finite set of
examples
it means that the problem is also
realizable in general so if
the problem cannot be solved over four
examples there is no way i can solve it
over all the infinitely many examples
and now i can give you the outline of
our algorithm which is very simple
i'm going to give you one angle first
and then we're going to try to improve
so the algorithm is basically is just a
reduction
so i'm going to take my science with
examples problem
and reduce it to a reachability program
analysis problem
so essentially i'm going to build the
program that is an assertion
and the assertion will always hold if
and only if the problem is analyzed
okay so i have a program a problem a
cyclist problem i'm going to build the
program
and an assertion in this program is true
it always holds if and only if the
problem is analyzed
so let's look at the construction so
first of all what does it mean for an
assertion to always be true well
uh basically it's a reachability problem
can i make the assertion false and what
we're gonna use in a reduction we're
gonna use non-determinism a lot
okay so this is something you're all
familiar with so i'm not gonna explain
what non-determinism is
but the point of this the reason i'm
excited about this is because
why do i want to solve a different
problem well because it's a problem that
someone else has already solved to some
extent
so there are many tools for proving
reachability
or for proving that an assertion is
always true so we can rely on those
tools to try to solve our own problem
so here it is the whole construction is
very simple so essentially i'm going to
build the program that takes my inputs
it runs my inputs non-deterministically
to one of the programs in my grammar
and then it's going to check that the uh
the specification i'm trying to
enforce is false so essentially this
program
this assertion is always f is always
true
if no matter which program i run my
inputs through
i will not satisfy the specification so
this is summarize here so i'm going to
repeat it
this program structure it has three
three blocks
takes the inputs runs the
non-deterministically through a program
in the grammar
and then checks if i not solve the
problem so if i can never solve the
problem
it means that the problem is analyzing
and now you kind of
can imagine what this looks like so my
assertion at the end is basically i'm
just specifying
hey if i solve the problem am i
satisfying the specification
so in this case i'm just checking is it
true sorry am i not satisfying the
specification
so is it true that i'm still not
satisfying the specification is it true
that for all these four inputs you
for at least one input you incorrectly
computed the max
and now the other bit the
non-deterministically drawn
is effectively kind of like a sketch so
i'm gonna have a program
that non-deterministically chooses what
to do and it basically mimics oh sorry
these are
shifted by one it mimics the grammar and
say i'm gonna non-deterministically pick
this production
so in that case i just returned zero i'm
not gonna know the thermistic repeat
this production in that case the return
one
if i pick x or y i i return the
corresponding component of the example
and for the sum and basically i
non-deterministically
choose a left child and
undeterministically choose the right
child
and then i sum them together so
basically this is an undeterministic
program that non-deterministically
chooses a program
in the grammar and runs it
so there is an issue with this that kind
of uh is
makes it different from things like
sketch uh
the problem first of all is that we have
an infinite amount of non-determinism
so every time we call this function we
can we can make a different on
deterministic choice
and that causes a big problem because
essentially when you run this function
on an input you get an output
of zero which is the output of some
program
in the grammar if i run this function
again on a different input
i get the output of some other program
in the grammar
and this doesn't guarantee that the two
programs are the same so if i do it this
way
my tool is incorrect because you might
tell that essentially
it allows different non-deterministic
choices to run different inputs on
different programs
but what i'm interested in is finding
whether running the inputs on the same
program
always results in the correct result
and the way you fix this is that you
basically instead of running one input
at a time we can run
all the input examples together so
basically you you kind of run them
pairwise
and you can see here for example when i
non-deterministically pick a sum
i i get the left side the right side and
then i pair
y
so we implemented this and we use
basically our q cycles
benchmarks to generate new benchmarks
that are analyzable
and essentially these are the ones is
like when you when i asked you before
can you do better than this can you find
a better program the answer was no
because there was no better program
and we were able to solve a bunch of
them so i'm not going to bore you with
the details
but one thing that didn't work is that
when the grammar was very large
these programs were resulting is very
big unrealizable
very reachability programs that existing
tools cannot handle
and so to fix this we built a new
tool for preliminarilizability and i'm
almost running out of time so i'm going
to just show you the high level idea
but the high level idea is very simple
here so this is a specific technique for
proving a realizability instead of
trying to use a full-blown and
reachability
reachability tool so consider this
grammar here
at the bottom and i have two examples i
want f of one to be five and f of two to
be six
that's my specification and my program
can only generate things of the form
of two forms basically x one or x two
let's look at the exponents so if you
look at look at this problem you will
see that basically what it generates
is an expression of the form it
generates a bunch of expressions and
each of them is of the form
two lambda x plus one okay where lambda
is can be anything
so now if you if if i tell you this it's
easy to see that
there is no solution because if no
matter what lambda i put here
i i'm in trouble because the thing on
the left here is always going to be
an odd number but on the right i want
something that is even
so there is no way that anything in here
will result in a solution
and similarly this one generates three
lambda and you get a similar problem
so all together they generate this type
of expressions
so if i were magically able to figure
out that this is the case
i could prove that this is unrealizable
in an analytic fashion
and this is the entire idea of our uh of
this other work we've done
essentially from the grammar we generate
a set of equations
that describes all the possible outputs
these grammar
programs in this grammar can produce and
then by
solving those equations we find all the
outputs
and now if the output we care about 5 6
is not in that set
we have proven analyzability and there
are two ways to solve this
you can one is basically you can encode
with inductive relations you can call
the
you can encode the problem of solving
the equations and we've done these using
off the shelf
uh on clause solvers or
and this is the part that perhaps you're
most interested in in the particular
case of linear integer arithmetic
you can show that these equations can
always be solved and result in what is
called a set of semi-linear sets
and this is quite exciting because
basically proves that
for conditional linear integer
arithmetic sizes
over examples is actually decidable you
can always prove
analyzability or or the problem is
solvable and you can find a solution
and the tools kind of perform
differently i'm not going to show you
too much but
to conclude basically we can add a
number of quantitative
and interesting guarantees to synthesis
and i show you how to do it for cycles
but one thing we are working on is going
beyond cycles because psychos
is only interested in expressions and
synthesis problems or expressions
but people are interested in many
problems so i want to conclude the talk
with a pointer to our new paper
where we extend syntax guided synthesis
to arbitrary domains so basically we
introduce a framework called semantics
guided synthesis that is hoping to be
what cycles
is for smt expression semantics guided
synthesis
it will be the that form that the
problem format but for
any synthesis problem and so i'm over
time so i'm going to start
thank you loris um are there any
questions from the audience
i'll always here is thank you for the
nice talk a quick question uh if i
understood correctly the
uh for q sigus you consider the
synthesizer itself to be a black box
right yeah so would some algorithms be a
better fit
than others that's a great problem so i
i guess a few cycles there are two
things there is the format and algorithm
so uh the q side was algorithm we do
black box because this way it was easy
to use
but if you actually do something like
what the amina does with meta sketches
where you incorporate the problem in the
loop or what sketch does also with this
linear search
you can reuse the facts you learn at
each step and improve your search
and actually we've tried it in in zengus
we also tried incorporating weights
and it's it's a little tricky
this linear search doesn't give you good
good inductive facts
the solvers that use these numeric
objectives
if the objectives are not tied in
interesting ways to the structure of the
program
then the solvers actually struggle to
use them in
in to use lemmas but i think you're
right that in some cases it would be
possible to do so basically
improve the search so that you don't
just black box call and you try to learn
facts
but i would say that even in the case of
metasketches and
the the sketch system kind of the
algorithm
itself the inductive synthesizer right
this is a black box
in in both cases it is sort of a sad
solver kind of thing
but i was thinking at that level if you
used sort of
some properly structured enumerative
solver
then you might be able to get those
costs
uh bounds for free yeah actually
well okay i do understand if that's the
answer the answer is no
because in all the benchmarks we have
there are infinitely many programs at
each at each tier
so you will never be able to prove that
you've explored everything below
so that's i guess in meta sketches you
can do that but in what we have if you
want to prove that there are
that's what happens with the example i
show the best solution at one if then
else but there are infinitely many
solutions with zero finances
so you can enumerate like kind of
dovetailing and eventually get something
but it will not tell you that you found
the best
oh i see so just that unrealizability
part is the
yeah um i mean even if you find a
program if you if you do duct taping
you at some point you find a program of
cost 10 you still haven't exhausted
anything of cost less than 10. so it
might be that you haven't found
there was a problem of cost six it was
just not in your enumeration order
so in some cases you can do that but in
general you cannot
right but yeah i see i see but
infinitely many programs with zero if
the analysis
uh would be also infinitely
large right correct i mean their cost
would be zero but it is sort of an
unnatural cost
yeah yeah exactly so that's why we have
those multi objectives as well
so if you want you can compose them and
that helps you but you're right
for some some cases that's what we
started with for some some cases you can
do that
and enforce a total order that allows
you to basically
it's an enumerative set that you can
give in algorithm but it's very
it's very interesting like extracting
that from the specification is a very
interesting question if you can do it
thank you loris thank you
thank you loris yeah
let's move on to our next speaker um
so super thick please go ahead and
project your screen
um so i'm delighted to welcome
our second speaker professor suprathik
chakrabarti
suprathik is a professor at the
department of